call of duty vanguard is coming to war
zone a mobile clone looks a lot like
modern warfare and the gta trilogy on
switch may require a few downloads i'm
persia and this is your gamespot news
let's kick this one off with some call
of duty news hot off the press
activision finally revealed the details
of vanguard's upcoming integration to
warzone later this year with season one
of post-launch content season one starts
on december 2nd bringing a new warzone
pacific map called caldera that will
introduce new modes including some
dogfighting prior to the start of
warzone pacific players will also get
limited time modes in verdansk to say
goodbye to the map as well as learn
information about caldera before the
integration the first mode is operation
flashback which is described as an
encore for verdansk and begins on
november 18th with the map leaving all
together on november 30th this is a
limited time mode that is said to
feature plenty of surprises that cover
the map's history over the last 18
months caldera will arrive on december
2nd with the launch of season 1. call of
duty war zone is a free-to-play game but
vanguard players will get 24 hours of
exclusive access to the new caldera map
at the start of the season during this
exclusive access warzone's smaller
rebirth island map will remain unlocked
for everyone else to play warzone
pacific will also bring the arrival of
the recently revealed ricochet
anti-cheat system to hopefully help cut
back on warzone's ongoing cheating
problem and being built on the same tech
and engine as call of duty vanguard
warzone pacific will support fully
optimized cross play cross progression
and cross gin support
but okay let's stick with cod and talk
about some mobile action as you may
already know activision has its own
stakes in mobile gaming with call of
duty mobile but now another company has
entered the mobile space with a
first-person shooter called combat
master online fps and call of duty fans
are calling it an apparent mobile clone
of modern warfare 2019
combat master online fps doesn't just
have similar gameplay and a nearly
identical gunsmith feature has called
the duty modern warfares but many of the
assets for the game's menu look like
direct copies of modern warfare 2019
content creator pro reborn tweeted a
video that shows them navigating the
menus and playing a match of combat
master which also showcases nearly
identical animations and text from
modern warfare's post game after action
report screen developed by alpha bravo
inc this call of duty clone currently
has over 500 000 downloads in the google
play store with a 4.5 rating as of this
recording combat master online fps is
still available to download and play but
it's uncertain how long activision will
let this apparent clone slide without
any legal action
and speaking of games you can play on
the go if you've been thinking about
playing metroid dread but you're new to
the series and worried you might not
like it well fear no more because out of
nowhere nintendo has announced a free
demo for metroid dread and it's out
right now you're welcome
in other switch related news it seems
like part of the physical version of the
grand theft auto the trilogy the
definitive edition on the hybrid console
needs to be downloaded separately as
reported by vgc the switch version of
the gta trilogy has appeared on the u.s
market website along with new details
and what looks to be the official box
art the box also has a disclaimer that
reads download required c back and
although the back of the case isn't
actually shown the nintendo eshop says
that 22 gigabytes of space is required
to download the trilogy on the eshop the
definitive edition appears as a bundle
containing the three gta games as
separate products however it seems that
the grand theft auto vice city will need
a separate download both when bought
physically and digitally it's unclear at
this time why vice city requires a
separate download and rockstar games has
yet to comment but in other gta news san
andreas is coming to vr via the oculus
quest 2 headset it's not clear when gta
san andreas vr's version will be
released on the oculus quest 2 but
according to the page on the oculus site
the title has been many years in the
making
it really does feel like gta is coming
to every single platform possible how
are you feeling about having san andreas
on vr let me know in the comments below
and of course leave a like and subscribe
so you don't miss your next episode of
gamespot news we'll see you later
you